hello and welcome once again to Android
design in action i'm your host Roman
Nurik hey guys my name is Adam Kosh hi
my name is Nate butcha and we are back
from hiatus we took a nice long break to
give ourselves some time to prepare for
Google i/o 2013 and now that the
conference is over we now have a chance
to talk about all the cool things that
that were announced all the different
sessions all the wonderful design
sessions that took place and that's what
we'll be doing today so with that let's
just jump right in because we have a lot
to cover since there was a lot that
happened that I am so the first thing we
want to do is look at all the different
sessions that took place there are a lot
of design sessions this year I know
exactly how many something like seven or
eight or something but they're all
jam-packed with with different bits of
information on a variety of different
topic subtype expand design so the first
that we want to talk about is racial
garbs and helena Robers session enchant
simplify and amaze Android the design
principles so I mean I guess like the
way we should probably do this is we
should all you know we should need to
talk a little bit about how you know
what takeaways there were for us for me
that the big takeaway here was kind of
the the association of emotion positive
and negative emotions from this from the
session you know the rather the
association of positive and negative
emotions with with kind of you is and
kind of how those play together there's
a lot of kind of interesting things
about about writing guide and things
like that yeah and I guess for me it's
interesting because I think Rachel
introduces the the the vision as the
sort of being touchy-feely and for me it
was always hard to sort of wrap my head
around how that relates to design for
myself because I'm more of a developer
and so I really like the examples that
she gave like actually showing how like
for example when one of the ones here is
own decide for me but let me have the
final say you can see there so for
example when you're deleting a message
it deletes first and then there's an
undue action rather than a dialog
yeah so same thing is how they actually
applied these you know very very snappy
kind of their principles and how she
showed how they actually help them
inform their design decisions so there's
a section in there where they're
assigning you know marbles for things
you do well and you know bad marbles for
things to do badly and really helps you
to weigh up different design decisions
and I thought that was already
interesting to me yeah they also
mentioned very briefly the Android
baseline study that we conducted about a
year or two ago that was kind of one of
the foundations of a lot of these design
principles that's kind of I think it's
mentioned someone near the beginning so
it was really kind of a really good
overview of other design principles and
I think of the the closest page on a
design guide to this session is
obviously the creative vision design
principle section which kind of goes
through all of them so they went through
that in excruciating Lee good detail so
that was a good session should we move
on to the next one yeah so next was
agile UX research practice in android
this is by Amica kono and bethany fong
and so here they go through a bunch of
different techniques that the Android
team uses as well as you know you know
lots of different companies out there a
couple of different techniques for
really lightweight really cheap research
stuff that doesn't involve you know
millions of dollars or thousands of
dollars whatever it's stuff that you can
basically do like one of my favorites
was the cafe study you go into like a
Google cafe or rinse like a starbucks or
something you just show your app or show
a very specific flow within your app to
a few people and kind of measure their
reactions in certain ways so it's very
very lightweight and very quick hence
the name agile yeah i'll admit i
actually haven't got around to watching
this particular session yet but it's
unlike to do this yeah these are each
like 40 minutes or so so I mean it was a
lot of sessions to work yeah I like the
way they get laid out the UNIX
traditional research process it's like
this day for my visitation weather
station and said you know there's no way
that's gonna work
world where the pace of mobile app dalam
is just too agile and they can really
compress it down so boy is really really
interesting how you can you know they
stress how important to do researchers
but showed how to do in an agile way we
really really really great and in the
very beginning they have this kind of
list of I guess this uh this grid not
really great I guess a chart of the
different techniques that you could use
and they focused more on the qualitative
and behavior side of things so right
around here they didn't really spend too
much time talking about the other stuff
because sometimes it can cost more some
of it is kind of outside of the scope of
kind of a small research team so
definitely you know if you're interested
in this kind of area this general area
of UX research they talk about a whole
bunch of techniques and here i think
that i think the major four techniques
they talk about they actually also spent
a lot of time on the pulse study i think
they went into the most detail about
this pulse study so yeah UX research the
next session was cognitive science and
design this is one of my favorites alex
is a tremendously good speaker he was on
the show in the think it was the most of
the notifications his notifications and
something else some process yeah
wouldn't processor yeah so he was on the
show and he talked about that and he's a
he's a tremendously good speaker and he
did a session on cognitive science and
design so he mentioned a couple of
things to get stopped principles he
mentioned things like proximity closure
etc we could see here this kind of
triangle and so on this is actually
really important because it it's one of
the fundamental basis of the holo visual
language kind of this use of space and
typography to communicate hierarchy and
structure you can kind of see that right
even without a whole bunch of lines you
can still make an association or kind of
form a mental model of the the
relationship between these different
groups of circles right so it's kind of
one of the fundamental basis for the
holovision language so it's kind of a
good session for that yeah I think I'll
saying the room and this session
regardless of Android or design or
anything else it's just really really
interesting to watch and one particular
slide I like that I don't think we have
it here
it it had a bunch of different shapes
and then their weight colored in
different colors as well I mean he sort
of showed how the colors are very easy
to spot the differentiation but the
shapes are not so again applies back to
sort of the whole of holo visual
language using spacing and contrasting
colors to differentiate yeah he also
mentioned affordances and actually
really like this slide you know there
was the previous slide that showed a
bunch of similar trash K similar-looking
trash cans of different colors and then
this slide showed trash cans with
different colors obviously but also
different slots and that kind of the
afford different types of things being
put inside them so this is kind of a
more effective type of trash / recycling
combination and one other that I really
liked was a slide about peripheral
vision so like you know he used this
really funny analogy of a kind of like a
tiger you know or you walk into a room a
test study and the first thing you see
is a tiger and he kind of did the study
or something or I guess this is based on
a study your response time to things
right in front of you is actually slower
than your response time to things around
you and so kind of peripheral your
peripheral vision is very important and
that's actually one of the reasons that
a lot of things on Android are near the
corners and edges of the screen rather
than in the very dead center and i think
selicia total is phenomenal yeah it's
really good it's really really good oh
one last thing I wanted to mention since
this talk is so good he also talked
about recognition so like the ability to
your ability to recognize people's faces
and versus their names your ability to
recognize their faces is something like
almost constant time like within like a
hundred people you'll instantly
recognize your friends versus in a list
of 100 names it will take you a while to
find that your friends names so really
kind of interesting tidbits here in
there probably spent a lot of time on
this and let's just move on the next the
next session was also very very good it
was by yen's Nagel and rich Fulcher on
the Android user experience team they're
both interaction designers and this
session they basically covered
navigation and really
or higher level structure so rather than
looking at a nap as a set of pixels or
you know set of individual screens they
looked at it as a whole and they talked
about different types of I guess they
use this kind of use case modeling
practice to to look at or to plan out or
map out an application so they wanted
took a little bit of depth on this kind
of barkeeper app where they basically
you know like look at different people
and their different use cases and map
them out in this kind of not only a
flowchart but more like a diagram and
this helped them kind of make decisions
about what navigation structures they
should use in the app one of my favorite
picks in this talk is where they explain
some of the design decisions behind some
of the google or android livestock
outside the calendar and so forth so you
know they went through the process of
how they arrived at the particular
navigation structure they use and you
know it showed variations and why they
wouldn't work and so for which it was
really interesting yeah I thought it's
just really useful how they show I think
of several examples where they show what
a nap could look like with tabs with
with the spinner with the drawer I don't
know if they show examples of the six
pack or dash yeah that is but it is
almost never the property actually there
was no it was never turned out to be
worth while selecting but I thought I
thought I was really useful just because
you know it applies to any app you could
sort of go through these different
iterations and see how would work with
these different patterns and certainly
there's pros and cons to each of them
which I think was the takeaway yeah I
really like how they kind of separate
out the structure into or they have a
couple of common patterns for
recognizing structure right so they look
at apps that may have a specific focus
like one of the top level sections is
the most important and then apps that
are very deep where they have kind of
like an equal weighting of sections but
each section itself is very deep and
then they look at another kind of type
of pattern or structural pattern where
an app is very very interconnected which
is this case so it's really kind of a
good way of structuring or thinking
about your app rather than thinking
about you know its features or
you know the individual components think
about it as a whole like what are the
different types of use cases that you're
trying to solve for different users and
then of course they spent a fair amount
of time talking about the navigation
drawer print as well so this is I think
you answered it made an excellent point
about how this is a community pan that's
emerged and how we've spent our time
kind of taking a look at all the
different community implementations and
what works well and what we felt could
be improved slightly and how we've just
dated on that process and really put a
lot of lot of thought and effort into
providing some guidance that we hope
will really make in a solidified of
space if people have some stability of
expectations of how this works exactly
yeah so the navigation drawer was one of
those patterns that was introduced in
agains and richest talk and Nick and I
covered it later which we'll talk about
but definitely it will probably do
another full episode of a DA on just the
navigation drawer at some point suddenly
what is Omega yeah yeah for sure alright
so moving on then Nick and I did a
session called Android design for you I
developers and this was kind of more
like a developer talk it wasn't really
so much for designers but I think
especially Nick's part the responsive
design area this is incredibly useful
for both designers and developers so at
a very high level we covered navigation
we so we've covered how to implement the
navigation drawer for example the Nick
did a whole big bid on responsive design
techniques and they compared you want to
talk about their here and then I I
finished off with implementing the holo
visual language like how to implement
dividers and and touch feedback and
different things like that yeah I took
the opportunity of having a the stage I
I still vote on my favorite topics is
responsive design so went about it I
talking about some of the limitations of
the kind of scalable approach and and
discuss some strategies you can use to
really like it to deal with that to cope
with it yeah there's very very good
information especially for developers so
if your designer and your developers
come back to you and say oh that's going
to take too long and I don't know how to
do it whatever just point into this
session there's a lot of good
information yeah I have nothing else to
add other than a good watch this session
it's good
alright so next we had oh actually
really quickly two things that we again
talked about for developers the
navigation drawer and the Nick talked
about sliding pane layout which is a new
sort of new presentation for master
detail views and google hangouts as an
example of an app that uses this we're
basically on a phone it's a single pane
that kind of slides off the screen to
reveal the master pain and on a tablet
they're both visible at the same time
there's obviously a lot more detail to
that pattern there but in case your
developer and looking to implement that
basically look at the navigation drawer
guide here with this link at the top and
then the sliding pane layout link is
kind of a link to the reference there's
no actual design guide topic for sliding
pains right now but that's kind of the
best place to look at for for basic
information about it obviously in this
session as well yeah so for those
watching our awesome producer hundred
has just told us that nyx audio is yet
again on only the left channel sorry
about that if you can't hear Nick and
only one ears plugged in I just switched
to the other ear sorry about that will
successfully to be my speaking at the
corner of my mouth again yeah exactly um
alright so next so this is actually an
interesting one an engineer's a
pragmatic guide to design from braden
calots I heard about this but there's
still no video up so we heard we all
heard good things but there's no video
up so we haven't had a chance to watch
it because we couldn't attend in person
so yeah it was king forward to watch it
looks really good that's all I can say
but just to check out this link down
here at the bottom I'm sure the YouTube
video we posted at some point it's just
a matter of time but yeah probably going
to be a really good session or if it was
really good session you were there feel
free to you know say so in the comments
and then there was another session from
from some YouTube folks on designing
products for a multi-screen world the
YouTube perspective I things from Tom
Braxton and Josh session that's right
and my favorite thing about this was
actually these these kind of charts they
basically did a whole bunch of research
into how people use their devices so
this wasn't an Android specific talk
this is basically looking at android
iphone TV ipad android tablets every
screen that you could post yeah
basically every every screen that lets
you go day yeah and so they created
these kind of like little diagram
journals of how people use their devices
so this is basically like a time graph
where I think it's just kind of a full
day and they just highlighted the
portions where people were using their
devices and so they made kind of little
observations around like people mostly
use their phones throughout the entire
day kind of snacking a little bit at a
time whereas at the TV portion of your
usage was more towards the nighttime
obviously with very very kind of heavy I
guess continuous portions so kind of
some of these some of these charts were
very interesting to watch and they've
definitely some good observations I'm
yet to see it yet but I think it's a
really interesting space as well how we
deal with the multi-device like when
everyone has all these different devices
he was really interesting Oh another
thing that was really good about this is
that they spent so YouTube is is
obviously a very popular brand and one
of the things is very important to them
is maintaining their brand across
different platforms and there's
especially a part at the end where they
talked about you know how do they
reconcile their brand with the platform
and then I guess I think it was Tom that
mentioned this but he's basically like
you know we want to be true to our brand
and we want to be true to the platform
but we don't want to sacrifice one or
the other so like if if you're working
with somebody or you know product
managers or or developers that are
thinking you know we really neat or
designers that we really need you know
this to be fully brand consistent
they're definitely kind of ways to
achieve that while not
I guess not letting kind of platform
conventions you know stop you or
anything like that yeah it's a very
common question we get asked around that
yeah and I think we want to do another
session just on this at some point I
think we should do an entire show on
that subject yeah there's a lot to talk
about there alright so moving on from
the sessions those are just some of the
sessions I think they're probably more
design was probably mentioned in more
areas but we also had a few labs or I
guess workshops at i/o that were related
to design the first was from Nazmul and
Isabelle UX design for developers this
is a very very popular workshop and it
was actually i think it was so popular
and there was too much overflow i guess
too many people trying to get in the
couldn't that they actually had to redo
this session they did two versions of
the session just to fit the demand so
this is an incredibly popular session
they also talked about use cases just
like rich and genz did in their talk
they also talked about personas so
basically the process of doing some you
know high level you know you x i guess
you know thinking through the ux for
your product you know thinking about
who's using it and then thinking through
the different use cases in prioritizing
them so basically they went through the
process I think of doing this for a like
pizza ordering type app and is basically
a lot of folks just wire framing and in
a you know diagramming out on paper so
as you can see note on these labs
unfortunately slabs won't record it yeah
and so you you won't be able to watch it
but some materials might be available if
you want to work through the lab in your
own time yeah so so these links here
aren't two videos these links at the
bottom are to the materials so for this
UX design for developers lab this link
actually points you too I think is a
developers live com or developer life
complex UX they started kind of a blog
and also a Google+ community just for
this for this project
and it's very very popular so if you're
interested in in kind of a UX design if
you're just in learning about it
definitely this is a very good beginner
I guess guide to it moving on then Nick
Adam and I we also ran our Android
design in action live lab and I was also
quite popular we only did one of these
but basically what we did is we kind of
took an alternative approach to a very
similar problem rather than you know
doing the standard classical you know
personas and use case of stuff we
thought about it a little more from an
engineering standpoint you know
different objects you work with the
different kind of connections between
them and the different ways to group
screens and such and so for about two
hours folks came to the session or came
to the lab they worked in you know with
pencil and paper and we gave out sketch
pads and things like that and we just
kind of had a whole bunch of fun going
through the process of creating a mobile
banking application for teenagers which
is kind of interesting little problem my
favorite thing I'd say about this was
these guys I mean everybody that was
there everybody that came thanks for
coming one of my favorite things that
happened was that we actually got
together a whole bunch of folks from the
design community like Taylor Ling was
there we had Lucas Roca Orisha from
pattern walmer from from Brazil whole
bunch of folks were there as TAS so they
walked around and help people as they
had questions would you guys think of
the the experience of the live lab I
thought it was really cool I mean it was
a definitely something we haven't done
before like normally we're used to doing
code labs at Google i/o so it was
something new and different and I was
just really impressed with all the work
that the attendees came up with at the
end so I think we may post some of those
at some point yeah it's some points
there we go yeah I I made sure to
capture the G+ profiles of all the
winners well the winners I think we the
TAS selected like four or five different
apps to I guess to win
but we're sure that he said they're all
winners he big that's right as well we
are all they are all winners basically
it was it was really really good like if
we had I think this is a good photo of
it there were I don't know we said like
we had time for 10 or 15 presentations
but at least 30 or 40 people came up to
try to present their work which is just
kind of awesome oh and by the way these
were hand-sketched designs in the end I
some people did use their computers but
for the most part they'll hand sketch
which was really cool yeah pursue things
I liked about lab boys and because it's
a developer conference and we pulled the
audience who is primarily developers
there and we said you know we want to
introduce you to the concepts how you
know you think through your application
and sketch it all out rather than just
you know which I think a lot of people
do is dive into the code too quickly and
you know build and invest a lot of time
is something which then won't throw away
so it's really interesting to get people
thinking about sketching and like
thinking through the problem space a lot
more you know find the design rigor a
lot more before jumping to code which is
really interesting and also on a second
it was great to meet a bunch of the
people so and some of the really active
people were the Android design community
so you might have seen them joining me
over the ABA hangouts we've had a couple
of times and posting on and the G+
community on the hashtag a dia and
Android design it was really great to to
meet this guy yep ROC totally okay so
that was the lab and again if you're
interested in running through it at home
just visited this this link here and it
pointed to a Google Drive folder
containing all the slides and everything
alright jada and a /a dia life yeah Dre
done in p / ed a life alright so I think
that was it for I oh actually oh wait no
there's there is more do we miss oh no
that's right that's right it's part of
the news so we there's more obviously
with Google i/o 2013 will mention a
couple of things about apps that were
launched google apps that were updated
but actually before we talk about the
awesome a day android app any kind of
parting thoughts for Google i/o 2013 the
in-person experience for me I was just
great to see a heavier design focus than
previous years sort of especially in the
Android side of course yeah it was just
a really great vibe there yeah really
enjoyed it yeah yeah for those of you
who didn't get to attend there's a bunch
of stuff that happens at i/o kind of
that isn't like recording sessions and
so on so we were involved a bunch of
panels for example where we're meeting
developers who were talking about you
know how they found success or their
experience in Android and one of the
things that came through for me was the
importance of Android design a lot of
businesses were saying you know this is
like impacted numbers we care about like
install numbers revenue and so on
because we've had talked to the Android
design principles so I think it really
shows the maturity of like the android
user base out there and how they really
appreciate a well-designed out yeah and
actually some of that is captured in the
biz dev bites video series that we
published around the same time as I oh
so if you're interested in hearing kind
of real-world product managers designers
developers talk about their experience
not only was a design guide and using
things like responsive design but also
just with with the impact of those types
of things those kind of technical
changes the impact on that on their kind
of key numbers the things that they care
about definitely check out the biz dev
bite series on Android developers the
YouTube channel so yeah my parting
thought is you know it was obviously
awesome to you know to meet everybody
again it's it's always kind of stressful
for you know folks on the Android team
or I guess anybody working at Google
that's staffing io to take care of but i
think this year more than other years is
a little more relaxed and I was
definitely able to engage more in like
kind of friendly conversations with
developers rather than you know jumping
around between different places so it
was definitely an awesome conference if
you didn't it didn't get to attend this
year you know definitely try to attend
next year and uh yeah here's the google
i/o 2014 alright so the let's talk about
the adi android app so i'm gonna butcher
his name unfortunately andreas stitch is
that so sorry if we print em pronounced
it wrong andreas really sorry but this
app is awesome i just hope no it's
really good we actually have it here
actually going to quickly switch over to
it so this is the app it's basically
lets you know look at past episodes of a
dia lets you look at all the slides what
to watch the videos notifies you of
upcoming eaters playing an episode in a
day in a dia yeah let's see if we can do
the insect let's see if we can do the
current one that's Oh No yeah it's
working oh it's get delayed so we don't
see the screen of the screen is great
yeah so so you can basically watch
Android design in action you can also
participate in some of the some of the
you know Google+ conversation google+
activity on android design and hash a
dia and it's just an overall well-built
app too so it's it's just a good example
of a well-built responsive design like
responsibly design how o app just
awesome app all around definitely
recommend downloading it Thank You
andreas it's been really useful for me
so a bunch of people you know they come
up and asking for design feedback and I
can say hey oh yeah we talked about this
on on a dia and I can put up my tablet
and pull up the redesign very easily
search you have nominal to be able to
have that yeah for sure so next this new
tool called well I guess this old
existing tool scala preview first of all
it now has an android version so you can
actually mirror what what's on your
computer to your android device very
similar to the Android design preview
the tool that we talked about I think a
few few weeks ago but this net this is
now free and it also works over Wi-Fi so
basically the almost the same thing as
Android design preview but it works over
Wi-Fi probably has a few other features
I haven't used it myself but it's
definitely good if your if your designer
and interested in seeing kind of real
world I guess real world scenario is how
your designs look in you know on those
devices so yeah so that's now free go
ahead and get it and then surreal so
actually one of the things that we
should jump to the yes first yeah yeah
let's do this one first so there are a
couple of new app updates out of the
came around the time of google i/o the
first and i guess the biggest to me is
is the google play music redesign so
this is so first of all we launched
google play music all access which is
kind of you know
it's a monthly subscription you get you
know whatever music and as part of that
launch we we also updated this new UI so
we I think like one of the best things
about this is that first of all uses new
patterns and things of that it's
obviously a very you know responsive app
it has a very good control it's got the
dryer yeah but it's also just it's got
it's filled with interesting you know
design touches like you know fading
trading semi-translucent action bars and
and like lots of different swipeable
panels it's just really cool overall I
think you said phenomenal app it has
they let you say some design flourishes
in there they've really fought through
all the mind you to mean 2010 details
this work it's only a good you know 28
half an hour playing with it just the we
lose Nick Nick seems to a frozen up
alright well okay good yeah so what Nick
said and there was also google hangouts
which is a new app obviously it's kind
of like a some messaging type app lets
you kind of communicate with people via
you know obviously pictures text and and
a video using video hangouts but it's a
new app and it uses that sliding pane
layout that we talked about earlier and
there are a whole bunch of you know
other updates so there's obviously the
i/o 2013 nick is back thanks for coming
next sorry to a velocity the first time
is obviously also the the google i/o
application which will be open sourced
at some point the Google+ app got
updates whole bunch of updates across
the board the the Play apps especially
play music playbooks play magazines
we've kind of gotten this new consistent
visual styling across the board which
matches google play store okay Alice Lee
Knicks lost again right all right but
anyway so the reason we wanted to talk
about this really quickly is that one of
the O's design touches is this kind of
fading semi-translucent action bar and
surreal ma ta actually created or wrote
up a blog post on how to do this in your
own apps so here's just a very quick
present a kind of a couple of
screenshots of what it actually looks
like I think he's got a sample APK you
can just go to install if you want
actually play with it because I think
you have to see it in motion
to really sort of understand it but yeah
and then someone else has also turned
into a library on get out of here yeah
great stuff yeah I'm sure they'll
they'll link up at some point but the
idea is that you me you have this kind
of transparent action bar that shows
content at the top but as soon as you
start scrolling it becomes solid so it's
very cool effect definitely you know
worth considering for one of your apps
so that was that was that and then I
think this is though this may be the
last one last one is and this is I think
a few weeks old but in case you're
interested in using some of the like the
action bar icon pack icons so like
refresh and share and things that in
case you don't want to necessarily use
the illustrator version or the photoshop
version it's like a million different
versions available there's now a font
for this so you basically just install
this font it's kind of like wing dings
or web dings or symbol or whatever but
you can just you know type in the right
character and you instantly get that
icon so yeah it's point happy if you're
doing some wire frames will sound like
that if you want do some high fatality
war crimes you wanna you know do an
action bar and action with an icon and
text you can do releasing yeah it's just
it's one way to just improve your speed
up your workflow I just really should
remind your process it's very cool okay
so i think that's it that's all the time
we have today um that was a kind of a
whiz-bang tour of google i/o 2013 the
different sessions that we have the
different labs that were that took place
and also some of the news that came out
of that as well as some of the news
around that time so thanks for joining
and again we're trying to probably going
to try to get back into our regular
cadence of of Android design in action
episodes sorry for the very long hiatus
but we're now free we have nothing else
to do just kidding but yeah so I hope to
see you next week or the week after or
whatever so thanks I'm Roman Nurik see
you later guys my name's Adam Kosh
thanks very much unique betcha hey guys
fight fine